some paper okay now this is important  part the important part now is to drive  the Philistines  yeah right on Dean what have you got on  your hands now why have you got bags on  your hand tell me I can't get a grip  don't be scared come on tell me I've had  a phobia vanish smell the fish hasn't  got a head on forgot to say get the bags  off I'm gonna get real come on and then  from there the butter I can't want you  to paste the butter okay on the back of  the salmon okay Patsy now the idea  behind that okay  butter one side I've got the mustard the  other side and annouced and wash them  together lift up okay now in in sorry  okay with me  we can spin any thick and thin and we do  that to make sure the salmon cooks  evenly right that's good  Patsy right coming together okay yeah  that's it so much  yeah now I'm good